وينضم الان الينا من بيروت العميد الياس
حنا الخبيره العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
وسهلا بك عميد الياس معنا في الحصاد اذا
الاوكرانيون في البدايه كانوا يقولون
نحتاج دبابات الان يقولون نحتاج طائرات
حربيه ما الذي يمكن ان يحسم فعلا الهجوم
المضاد الذي
كثر وطال الحديث عنه ام ان القضيه قضيه
وقت واطاله وقت اكثر من اي شيء اخر
ليلى منظومه الهجوم العكسي او الكاونتر
اوفنسيف يلي يحضر له هو من ضمن مجموعه
ومنظومه يعني الدبابه لا تعمل لوحدها
الاليه المدرعه تحمل العسكر وهذه الاليه
والدبابه يلزمها دعم ناري من مدفعيه
وبالتالي يستلزم ايضا منع الطيران الروسي
من الاستعمال واتى في التقرير موضوع
الطائرات الطوافه لدعم الجبهات الاماميه
فاذا انت امام منظومه كامله متكامله ايضا
هي بحاجه لاستخبارات واستعلام تكتي كي
تنجح اليوم ما يجري في مخموط هو استهلاك
للقوى الروسيه من جهه والاوكرانيه من جهه
واليوم عندما نفكر في الحرب ليلى لا يمكن
لنا ان نستبعد ما اتى في هذه الوثائق
وثائق بغض النظر عن صحتها او سلبيتها او
ايجابياتها اغلب ما ورد فيها هو موجود كان
يقوله وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ما الذي انت لمسته في هذه الوثائق الذي
يمكن ان يؤثر على الحرب في المدى القصير
خطوره الوثائق اذا كانت صحيحه هي مده
اللايف يعني المده بين حصولها ونشرها او
تسريبها اربعين يوم هي تعكس الحاله
للجيشين الخلق الامريكي العميق للجيش
الروسي
لمخططاته واهدافه ووضعه وايضا يصف الجيش
الاوكراني على ان اي هجوم عكسي لم يعطي
النتائج المطلوبه والاتجاه العام هو نحو
ستين ميت او ما يسمى بالاستنزاف المشترك
فلنسلم جدلا الليله سقطت محمود بعدها ماذا
هل نذهب الى كراماتورسكو وهي اكثر بعشر او
15 مره من مخموت او نذهب الى سلوبيان فاذا
نحن امام مرحله من الانتحار المشترك بين
القوتين فاذا نحن امام الحديث مثلا عن
حمايه الحمايه الجويه
98% من الحمايه الجويه الاوكرانيه هي سلاح
من اصل سوفيتي للسلاح الاوكراني هي ليست
امريكيه وليست غربيه لانه القصف العنيف
والصواريخ والمسيرات لا يمكن لما اعطي من
سلاح غربي مضاد للطيران ومضاد للصواريخ ان
يكفي لهذا العدد طيب في قضيه الوقت هنا
وهنا اعود لسؤالي الاول يعني قضيه ان تطول
ان يطول امد الحرب وان الولايات المتحده
تظل تدعم بالاسلحه وهي مستعده لتحارب حتى
اخر جندي اوكراني كما يقال في الاعلام
الامريكي بينما الرئيس بوتين لا يمكن ان
يخسر لانه يعرف ان خسارته تعني نهايته في
وسط هذين الموقفين يعني ما هو مصير الحرب
على الارض ما هو مصير اوكرانيا بين هاتين
القوتين
المؤشرات التكتيكيه على الارض ليلى وهذا
نشرته مجله وجريده
هو
التحصينات
الكثيفه والمكثفه حول القرم وحول خط خرسون
او نهر
النيبروجيا لحمايه ميليتو بول وكانه يقال
بالمرحله القادمه هي مرحله الثبات في مكان
الانتهاء من مخبوط وقد تقف المعركه في
مكان ما وفلهم فلنات الى طاوله المفاوضات
وتبدا الخبر للقصه كما حصل في بالعامه 52
في في
كوريا بالحرب الكوريه فاذا هذه التحصينات
لماذا لمنع الهجوم والهجوم في مكان اخر
وكاننا نذهب الى ما يسمى بتحقيق بما توفر
والبقاء عند هذا الامر
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس حنا من بيروت